Hi!
I'm Ana.
Welcome to 'What to Say'!
Do you know what to say when you give advice?
Listen out for useful language for giving advice.
Then, we'll practise saying the new phrases –
after this.
Argh,
this is just ridiculous!
Susan again?
Yeah, Susan.
She just keeps emailing me about things that have nothing to do with work
and nothing to do with me.
What do you think I should do?
Well, if I were you, I'd email and ask her to stop sending them.
I'm not sure that's a good idea.
I have to be careful what I say as she's quite an important client.
Erm, I'm not sure then.
Perhaps you could try talking to Yuna about it?
Er ... why don't you try
doing nothing?
Sorry?
Perhaps you could just …
do nothing?
Really?
I'm not too sure about that.
Well, I remember this guy I used to work with,
Mark,
and he kept emailing again and again and again,
about all sorts, mostly unrelated to work.
Well, I kept responding politely
and he kept sending them.
In the end, I stopped replying to his emails
unless they were only about work.
And what happened?
He stopped sending them.
It's ...
It's a bit like being faced with a dangerous snake.
If you move quickly, it'll bite you,
but if you keep very still
and do nothing,
eventually it'll move away and leave you alone.
I had to learn the hard way.
Hey, Bob. Have you got a minute?
Yeah.
So, I tried what you suggested
and I only responded to Susan's emails about work for a few days.
Then guess what?
The irrelevant emails stopped.
Yes! Now she only sends me work-related ones.
Well, that's very good news.
All thanks to you, Bob.
Any time, Noelia, any time!
All in a day's work.
Ahh!
Hello again!
It looks like Bob is in Noelia's good books.
So, did you notice the useful phrases used for giving advice?
Listen to me and then repeat.
What do you think I should do?
If I were you, I'd ask her.
I'm not sure that's a good idea.
Perhaps you could try talking to Yuna.
Why don't you try doing nothing?
I'm not too sure about that.
I tried what you suggested.
Try and use some of these phrases the next time you give advice in English.
Bye for now!